In 1 Peter 3:15, Peter wrote this, But in your hearts set
apart Christ as Lord. Always be prepared to give an answer to everyone
who asks you, to give a reason for the hope that you have.
But do this with gentleness and respect.
Oftentimes when we're talking about things like apologetics, this verse is sort of
the foundational verse that everyone seems to cite.
Why? Well, because in this verse is where we get the idea of apologetics.
So Peter is asking us or commanding us to give a reason.
He's saying give an actual reason.
Well, what does it mean to give a reason?
Well, in this context, it means to give a defense, give some kind of
defending idea of what it means to, uh, about what you believe.
This is actually the Greek word apologia.
And that's where we get the idea of apologetics.
It literally comes from the word apology.
Now we're not talking about I'm apologizing for what I believe, but if you can
imagine for a moment, a courtroom scenario where you were on the stand and you had
to give sort of a defense. You had to give a reason for your actions, a reason for
what you believe, or a reason just for what you're doing.
Well in the ancient world, in the context that Peter is talking about here, is to a
bunch of Christians who are being persecuted by the Roman government.
Now here, Peter's telling the believers to be prepared,
to know why you believe what you believe, to be able to stand in a formal sense
in this context, to give a reason, to give a defense, to defend one's belief
in something. And we take this command that Peter gives the early Christians and we
said, you know what? We have the exact same responsibility in our day is to be able
to stand when the questions come and be able to give a reason for what we believe
and why we believe it. So essentially, this is what apologetics is, and this is what
you and your students are going to embark on this coming year.
But it's more than just making a defense.
It's the idea that we are both called, but we're also called to be capable.
See, it's more than just saying, I have to give a defense.
How are you going to give a defense?
What do you know to be able to stand there and tell somebody what you believe and
why. So this is exactly what we start to see, and what your students are going to
start to see with Peter in the early stages of Acts, right?
So if you look at what Peter says in Acts, you've got this guy who literally at the
crucifixion ran away, but then all of a sudden in Acts is
proclaiming what he's seen and heard.
and we see in Acts 4:20 Peter say we can do nothing but
speak of the things that we have seen and heard so they're just this massive
compelling nature of them to be able to speak about the things that they've seen and
heard now it is important to remember that some people might not really
think that this idea of apologetics is all that necessary in fact some might even
say it's dangerous and they might even look to passages like 1 Corinthians
chapter 2 where Paul gives this idea that it's not by human wisdom or
human power that he comes to the Corinthian church that he didn't come with wise
and persuasive words and a lot of people will take this to mean that we don't argue
and we don't want to persuade people but in the context that's not exactly what
Paul is talking about.
So we are called to maturity. We're called to be able to give evidence.
And we'll see throughout this study, if you look at the life of Jesus, you'll look
at the life of Paul, you'll look at the things that Peter did.
All of them gave consistent and good reasons for
what they believed and why they believed it.
So what we're really asking students right out of the gate here is to consider that
very question. Why do you believe what you believe?
And can you discuss those beliefs intelligently?
Why do you believe what you believe?
So, you and your students are headed on a huge, huge journey here, okay?
And it starts with getting students to start thinking about these kinds of spiritual
conversations.
Some of the stuff that we're going to be talking about is some pretty heavy stuff.
Some of the topics that we're going to be dealing with are going to be very
challenging, not only for you, but challenging for your students as well.
So you want to create a certain kind of environment.
Now, some of you may already have this environment in your groups and some of you
may not. But I want to encourage you to create an environment that really fosters
this key idea of being able to ask and answer questions.
now this might seem really really simple like well yeah of course my students can
ask questions but you would be surprised at the number of students that just don't
feel like they can ask any question they're not just the difficult
question but maybe the question that just
really questions their own faith that really sort of invites in this idea of
doubt now we're going to be dealing with doubt but much later so you have to be able
to create an environment where your students feel like they can ask anything.
Where they feel welcome, where it's a safe place.
But that doesn't mean that you have to have all of the answers.
Because let's be honest, you're not going to have all the answers.
Your students ask great questions.
In all the years that I've been a Christian educator, I have seen some amazing
questions that you just sort of stand there with your jaw dropping.
I don't know what to say to that because I never would have thought of that
question. And I love those kinds of questions.
Don't feel like you have to have all the answers.
But what goes even further than having all of the answers is being able to walk
alongside of a student and say, hey, listen, I don't know the answer, but let's
you and me figure this out together.
That's going to do exactly what our goal is.
That's going to create a stronger relationship between you and your students as well
as at the same time figuring out their, you know, the answer to their question.
So, use the resources that you have available to you inside your church.
Possibly a school or seminary that might be nearby.
Friends and family of yours that may have a deeper understanding.
But also, use us. We're here. At AwanaYM.org we have a
ton of resources and a library that we are continuing to build.
Definitely check out Sean's website at seanmcdowell.org.
He's got a ton of resources. And if you still are stumped, you can even contact us
directly and we are happy to help you in any way that we can.
We are here to assist you in this journey.
But I can't stress enough, be sure that your small group leaders and you
in terms of a large group, whatever it is that you have going on, make sure your
students feel like they can do this, that they can ask anything.
anything and it might start with you giving them some of the questions that even you
have in terms of figuring out what this looks like so get ready dive
in don't hold back and know that all of us here at the Home Office are praying for
you pray for each other and other groups around the country that are on this
journey with you as we navigate together, what this looks like as we
explore deeper of what it means to be believers in Christ, what that looks like, how
do we defend it, and how do we guide our students so that when they graduate, when
they move on to bigger and better things beyond your youth group, they are prepared
to successfully engage their culture and further the Kingdom of God.